You know, I thought that when we hit one million
YouTube subscribers a couple of months ago,
I thought things would calm down.
I think I believed everything would
normalize with a Sam Cedar's show, the majority
report. And just as a disclaimer, this is just a
joke. It's just a break from the serious stuff on
today's show. But let's pretend this is for real.
I was expecting that we would get past this silly
spat with the majority report. I never considered
that we were even in a battle with Sam to get
to a million subscribers. I think the battle was
was mostly going on in Sam's had, quite
frankly, and it might have been placed
there by a caller to both of our shows named
Ronald Reagan and possibly even by Hugo Chavez,
Nicolas Maduro and Cuba. But in any case,
Sam thought there was a race to a million
subscribers. And to the extent that there was
Sam lost that race. Now the race didn't exist.
I wasn't participating in it. But Sam lost
the nonexistent race. We didn't participate,
but we had a million subscribers. And then we hit
one point one million subscribers and now we have
surpassed one point two million subscribers.
And now good for Sam. OK, please remember,
I'm on Sam's team. I want what's best for the
movement, not just me. Now, finally, Sam Cedar
is approaching one million subscribers on
YouTube and I am the first to be here and issue
a preemptive a blanket. Congratulations to Sam
on very, very soon hitting a million subscribers.
Now, everything was going beautifully until
yesterday. A viewer gets in touch with Sam
and suggests that Dominion voting systems
may be counting YouTube subscriptions
and that exactly the same foul play
alleged in the 2012 presidential election
can be blamed for The David Pakman Show YouTube
channel hitting not just one million subscribers
before Sam, but one point one and one point two
million subscribers before Sam and Sam doesn't
even challenge this on his program. Even he seems
to take pleasure. He has this like, satisfied
grin on his face when this is brought up.
Take a look at this YouTube contract's dominion
to count subscriptions. So, so many people have
subscribed to Majorie report that it broke the
algorithm and set your subs to David Pakman.
This explains why he is not the one million
and he was born in South America.
So, you know, so it doesn't matter. Yeah. He
like John McCain running for president. Well, no,
I'm saying there's a connection that to be made.
Oh, yeah. Oh, right. I forgot our initial scheme
here. It was all about Venezuela interfering.
Even bringing up my South American heritage
is is actually. That's very low. That's ugly.
I'm I'm shocked, quite frankly, that Sam
Sam chose not to challenge those claims. No,
he seems to revel in it. She actually seemed to
think that there was something funny here. Now,
as a reminder, this is just a joke. We're friends
with Sam and Sam is doing great. And he's soon
going to be when Sam hits a. Now, this is serious.
When Sam hits a million subscribers,
he will be the fourth into the independent
progressive news type show on YouTube to get
to a million subscribers. Twitty, of course,
the big player with five million subscribers,
I believe we're at one point two million. Brian
Tyler Cohen recently made it over the line and
is over one million. And Sam Ceder about to enter
the one million subscriber club and we're looking
forward to welcoming him. But remember, this
is not a zero sum. You can subscribe to Sam
and to us and to see Whitey and to whoever
else you want to subscribe to. So please do.
I've got nothing to sell you here other than a
free, good time where at one point two million,
we're almost 200000 YouTube subscribers ahead of
where we wanted to be and hoped to be. By now,
we have the possibility of getting to one and
a quarter. That's one point to five million
subscribers by January 1st if you help us. So
let's make it. I've got nothing to sell you
here. I mean, listen, I have things to tell
you. I'm not selling them to you right now
here. I'm just saying participate, subscribe to
all of these channels. And if we can say one thing
about twenty twenty, it's that the growth that
progressive independent media has experienced
and there's two reasons for it. One is the pie
is actually getting bigger. I was interviewed not
long ago by Professor Richard Wolffe, my former
professor, on his program. And one of the things
that's going on is that more people now default to
looking on YouTube. For analysis and commentary,
so the pie is getting bigger, but also certainly
awareness of programs like ours, Sams, the Young
Turks and lots of others has been growing. So
let's keep it going into twenty, twenty one.